hey good humans derek here before we get
started we want to take a moment to
thank extra for sponsoring this video
extras on a mission to make credit
building safer and more accessible for
everyone when i started figuring out my
own finances building credit was such a
headache but with extra it's so much
easier extra's the first debit card that
lets you build your credit and earn
reward points just like a credit card
for all of you out there who either
don't want or can't get a credit card
this is the solution
right here
look at that
all you do is connect this card to your
existing bank account then extra spots
you for everyday purchases and you will
auto pay extra the next business day at
the end of the month all the payments
are added up and reported to credit
bureaus as creditworthy payments
and you can even earn redeemable points
for every purchase you make best of all
there are no credit checks no interest
and no hidden fees so anyone can get
started building credit whether you're
student or working and want to start
building or rebuilding your credit
extra's a great alternative to risky
credit cards so sign up for extra with
the link in the description and start
building your credit with a debit card
yeah i said it a debit card thanks again
extra now let's get started with the
video
well i think there's some people that
are fat and they love it but that's
probably who they are
you shouldn't be proud of being that
overweight
[Music]
what's the hot take again
audience submitted
questions mean
you can never be too big man
he could never be too big
he just wished too i mean there we go i
am big compared to what i used to be but
not enough to what i want to be yeah
you're going to want more you'll never
be awesome
never you'll never be satisfied people
do take it to an extreme like people
that injected their arms with like
synthol oil and then like the guy's
bicep busted open like crazy things like
that i agree with that i agree with that
yeah that's extreme
you know and they can't you know wipe
their butt on the toilet like that's
another form of body dysmorphia you feel
like you're never big enough i don't
think so bodybuilding is the extreme
there's nothing wrong with it it's never
going to be too much i would be
considered one of the larger ones and i
don't think i'm larger at all i can get
much bigger
male body builders have small penises
i'm excited to hear this so all right
i'm gonna go ahead and start this off
i'm speaking as far as myself that's
that's a disagreement but as far as
other bodybuilders i can't speak for
them i've never dated a bodybuilder so i
have never seen the goods of a male
bodybuilder hey if you're a guy and
you're backstage getting a tan you know
bodybuilders have to put a sock on of
course you're going to look around you
know
it must mean something one of the
biggest male members i know because it's
just so obvious when he steps on stage
beau lewis he's
huge down there you can't miss it
when you are a caliber above people try
to find a way to bring you down to their
level it's like you know
little penis energy like when you see
guys and like the flashy cars all the
designer clothes and all that you're
like what are you compensating for dude
that's true yeah
i build my body to get girls for guys
oh i love you daniel
sorry i mean i'm being brutally honest
right here uh i was always the skinny
kid so in the beginning was that but now
i have a girlfriend so
that's not the point anymore
i think i bodybuild because i want to
scare him away
so i just wanted to ask a question it
was because the girls liked you
regardless of the body or not right
because girls don't care about muscles
and stuff yeah they really i personally
think that girls like dad bods more than
fit guys
a lot of bodybuilders they get more
compliments than guys than girls it's
because it's a turn off for a lot of
girls they think you know when a guy is
too big or too shredded or too vascular
it kind of looks freakier scary to them
i care i watched my man go from being
160 pounds to over 200 pounds pure solid
muscle and like my physical attraction
just went oh my god look at you you're
like two feet wide this is amazing wow i
like them dad bods i'm sorry
here's the next prompt
i look down on people who are out of
shape
three
two
one go
i would never judge a person for being
out of shape it's just for me i started
off in the military and then when you
become a mom you know it's a slippery
slope to getting fat and to getting
chubby and getting that mom body and so
i know how it is to be out of shape and
i know that that needs a lot of tender
loving care and nurturing to get
yourself out of that mode of not being
fit again i mean people know when
they're out of shape they don't need to
be told they need to be loved and
nurtured to do the right things
i was bullied in high school i was 190
pound freshman i didn't even speak
english i moved here as an immigrant i
didn't like how i looked you know i was
made fun of in pe and that was up to me
to change that so you can do it you're
just choosing not to it so you're
basically talking about specifically if
someone says they want something but
they don't challenge themselves they
don't try those are the ones that you're
like
oh
i'm upset with you kinda yeah if i see
someone that's just playing video games
all day eating potato chips and not
doing anything else in their life i'm
like all right you know you could be
doing something else for your health we
all should be productive in a certain
type of way
but they're the ones that can make the
most gains you make those little steps
you walk every day you change your diet
you lift more i wouldn't want to be
discouraging to those people because not
at all not discouraging motivating them
you know like i would want them to do
something good for themselves you know
obviously yeah
you should not be proud to be back three
two one go
um i mean
when people hear the word fat it has
such a negative connotation to it when
like
why
i don't think fat is necessarily a bad
thing like being unhealthy is a bad
thing but there's a lot of pride that is
unhealthy we're talking about pride of
being proud of being that size
being accepting of yourself as fat and
being proud to be fat you should love
yourself in all forms but you shouldn't
be proud of being that overweight and
unhealthy and it's not going to be proud
yeah it's not it's really nothing to be
proud of it's it's something to accept
and love yourself for and not beat on
yourself for i think you can be proud of
it there's some people that are fat or
overweight and they love it but that's
proud to be who they are that's proud of
their body like oh and look how much i
can eat oh i can put my fat on top of a
car now this coming up on the layers
that i'm growing and that is
accumulating on my bite is causing me to
have heart disease and all these other
things that's the pride that i have like
being proud to be the thousand pound
woman well yeah is that you getting
government checks and things that's an
extreme fat comes in all different
shapes and sizes like if you're still
healthy on the inside and you like what
you got work it yeah i feel like the
problem is like when you are so proud of
being fat and then like you become like
an influencer that you influence like
younger generations to like have those
uh unhealthy life standards and say
that's just like body positivity well
there's some influencers that are fat
but they do work out you know on their
platform they're doing yoga and they're
dancing and so they're active but
they're just
overweight going back to the thing it's
not like something to be proud of at all
only because trust me they would not
want to be fat and they claim oh no i'm
happy i'm embracing with what i have no
if you could look a certain type of way
differently you would choose that over
this any other day well how do you know
that they would choose a thinner
physique over not necessarily a thinner
physique but you would want to look a
little different i know personally know
a lot of people that are like that and
deep down they do break down and tell me
no it's just like another way of them
trying to make themselves happy and
again it's totally okay but it's not
something to be proud of
you know i don't know it was a movie
like dodge ball right and it's like it
was like ben stiller character he was
like if you don't hate yourself enough
to do something about it it's not it's
your fault you know funny but it's just
one of those things like with lizzo and
everything else she does work out she
does want to lose weight she knows
that's not healthy but she still has a
certain about like i am still going to
be me and i'm fabulous no matter if i'm
100 pounds or 400 pounds i can
understand i can respect that but she
does have to delay the point that her
heart is working overlord bouncing that
ass up and down in a lot of ways though
uh bodybuilding i mean there's a lot of
negatives to what we do too that we
could be influencing other people
negatively you know like weighing our
food and always caring about every
little gram that comes into our mouth
and like i'll take that putting your
entire i'll take one over the other that
fat around your heart that that around
your intestines around your stomach is
dangerous so taking pride in something
that's just killing people like that
okay
i have considered steroids
three
two
one
i think in order to stay highly
competitive especially on the west coast
it's almost half necessary to start
using stuff because unfortunately to get
to the points that people are displaying
you need help i definitely agree i mean
this is a really touchy subject but with
all the respect for people who are
natural who don't obviously take
anything keep going
the sad truth about bodybuilding is
everyone you're going against is
probably on stuff i did my first show
natural i won that show but the second
show i got destroyed and i realized what
time it was everyone's talking behind
stage about this that if your goal is to
be in that top one percent to make it to
the olympian you're gonna be going
against people who are taking a lot of
steroids anabolics and it's not going to
be a fair battle for you it's just it
won't be it makes a huge difference to
you for sure yeah you do this sport
because you want to win right of course
you're not going to go on stage just
because you want to get second place
third place last place no it's too
expensive to just go on stage
so i said i respect the people who just
want to go on there and be natural yeah
respect for you and you know that's what
they have the natural leagues for too
there's drug tested leagues that if you
want to be within the people who do not
and will not use these things you can go
into the natural league and be tested i
do completely agree with all that
and again i compete in the mpc so that
is not drug tested but i've come a few
spots away from my pro card at nationals
a few times being completely natural
and i'm not against taking drugs i
understand most people do for those
bigger divisions it's a necessity like
you have to do it but for bikini i know
that i can make it to that pro level
being natural it's just gonna take me a
little bit more time
and i i take pride in that because again
i got into this lifestyle because of the
health benefits
for me i just never thought about doing
that because of like the long-term
consequences that it may bring if not
accompan by like a doctor or like a
professional
so i always wanted to like stay natural
but like if you're doing it in a healthy
and safe way then
you do you i guess
i i just
well i i have both experience from both
sides but i remember waiting and
thinking about how small i was and i was
thinking about how i couldn't get that
leanness and i remember i wanted to be
bigger and i was thinking in my head
like i could not freaking wait to find
me
a drug dealer so i can get on some
steroids because i wanted to be the
biggest i wanted to be the strongest and
i told anyone else if you see me and you
see me with big muscles you don't have
to worry about asking you don't have to
worry about spreading rumors because i
am definitely 100 on something it's not
abuse a lot of times when people talk
about doing performance-enhancing things
they want to talk about the mlb or the
mba or i'm not in any of those things
this is self-care for me to take care of
my body and for me to love what i'm
doing with it so it's not like something
where you end up having this situation
where you have roy rage or you have
someone who's angry all the time a
person is an [ __ ] they're an [ __ ]
it has nothing to do with what they take
so just being real and i respect you
being so transparent about it because a
lot of them just try to say oh i'm
natural like i did this and you can do
this too and it's just like no like why
are you afraid if you take peds then
just say that you do i don't i don't
understand the whole taboo around it and
i think that needs to shift but if more
people talked about it it would be less
severe if people were more open about
the safety and the care of it some
people do abuse it but it's just like
when people abuse anything alcohol
cocaine drugs anything is just being
smart and being educated about it
bodybuilding is good for my mental
health
three
two one go
so i have had like instances in my life
where i've been like really down and
depressed and so gym and bodybuilding
was one of the things that got me
through and it made me like forget my
problems and just like focus all my rage
and anger towards like hitting opr's and
stuff
so
thank you bodybuilding definitely can be
a mental relief to you you know that's
your only you time where you really get
to have when you're going to train
you learn your self-worth exactly
exactly definitely because it's you
versus you at the end of the day that's
how the sport is it's a selfish sport
but it helps you mentally it builds you
up for sure but the reason why i'm in
the agree lane and not in the strongly
agree lane is because i can never look
at food the same
what's clean and whatnot you can no
longer just walk into a restaurant look
at a burger and fries and eat that you
know you're always going to think no
that has cheese that has this i can't
digest that well you know but as far as
bodybuilding itself definitely helps you
yeah mostly help
i feel my worst post show because i get
so lean going into my shows that coming
out of them
i struggle mentally
and emotionally with it because i am so
and it's going to sound ridiculous
uncomfortable with how i look right now
so it is really good because it got me
out of a rut that i was in like
bodybuilding saved my life
but it also
created a new problem yeah the body
dysmorphia post show is real
yeah
if it wasn't for bodybuilding i can say
almost undoubtedly that i would not be
here right now i was in a very abusive
relationship
verbal sexual
mental um
and i was in a very dark place um and
during that time i started to get into
working out and i noticed like that it
was giving me
confidence and like an outlet and the
person that i was with was kind of
getting intimidated they told me
straight to my face if you compete i
will break up with you on the spot you
know that's selling your body for sex
that's that's what a [ __ ] does and so i
didn't end up doing it
um and a few months after that we
broke up um and that was probably the
worst spot that i was in coming out of
an abusive relationship and like just
being empty like for that period of time
that was the only person that i knew and
so
i was in a dark place and i almost took
my own life
and
i remember one day i was like sitting in
my car
and i was gonna drive myself out to the
beach and just walk into the ocean yeah
and that was the day that i was like you
know i'm gonna i'm gonna say
thank you to him and do a show
and i dedicated the next
four months of my life to prepping for
the show and that saved me it gave me
like a purpose it gave me that
independence and that strength it's
amazing it's amazing i just want to say
i'm really glad you're here because i
know that like what you're feeling
and um i've
gone through like breakup there were
like a few instances where i broke down
like all right in the middle of workout
i know it's embarrassing but
you know it got me through it no i'm on
the same boat with you man you know it's
just a constant battle in your mind just
thinking to yourself and i'm i'm glad
you're here sasha by the way
thank you
my body is the most important thing to
me
three
two
one
go
[Music]
obviously my family and god come first
and then there's my body but especially
if it's your dream to make it to the top
and everything it is your business it is
your investment that you got to take
care of constantly same you know
one-on-one season one-month competition
that's my borrowed time for myself at
six months i'm being the most selfish
that i can you know i'm not going
anywhere i'm not doing anything i'm not
eating out but once i'm out of prep then
yeah everything else comes first
sometimes those things take a precedent
if i'm in prep i'm sorry like i'm not
answering the phone but if i'm out of
prep and a friend calls and i was
supposed to get a workout in that day
looks like i'm not going to the gym she
needs me
so yeah yeah this is my money maker so
i'm competing in three weeks so this is
yeah this is everything to me right now
so if i'm hurt or
something feels funny i'm making sure
i'm taking special attention to it
people want to go rollerblading or
hiking or things like that i can fall on
a rock and scratch and break something
before the show and then look like an
idiot so just no
no this is this is the time to be really
focused absolutely zero in on me
i feel like you need your body to be
healthy in order to have anything else
of course mental health is very
important as well but i feel like like
once you're physically healthy like your
mind could be at ease we're only given
one body and so i feel like we should
take good care of it i'm not i'm not
looking at it from a vanity perspective
um i'm looking at it from my body is my
temple
and like nothing feels better
than being in shape and there's like
that quote out there like oh like
nothing tastes as good as skinny feels
i'm just like yeah whatever like nothing
feels as good as making it to the top of
that mountain or like kayaking for six
hours straight and like still being able
to keep going
like that it's just such a great feeling
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
oh